what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started but before we start guys I
almost forgot get yourself a women's
shouldn't vote t-shirt today all of
these crazy divorce laws all of this
craziness in society really in my
opinion started because women got the
right to vote I think we should take
that [__] away
um today I was told
that I woke up this week and chose
violence now really I think that
violence chose me okay I I think you
know and based on the way you guys talk
emotional abuse chose me because
according to conservative Twitter
yelling is emotional abuse and everybody
on Twitter yells at me so I am in an
unsafe work environment I am just uh uh
my emotional abuse every day I get on
Twitter and I just cry I cry every night
um because of you know all my my
insecurities and just uh
right now so this week um I didn't even
I didn't even think this would happen I
was like this is amazing I went from
watching The Daily wire in high school I
used to watch them all the time okay to
now arguing with them on Twitter I don't
even want to say arguing debating
this is amazing so I got responses from
Jeremy Boeing Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh was
the big one and Jordan Peterson now guys
I I'd like to say I am attacking ideas
not people so I have I am a fan of the
daily wire I think they're awesome but I
do think they're very wrong and naive
when it comes to marriage I actually
felt like the daily wire lied to me in a
way as like a consistent viewer for 10
years you know they would really preach
marriage and family as the solution but
they never talked about why men don't
want to get married and the risks
associated with it and it's kind of like
a weird you know trajectory when you
realize that we're in a post-marriage
society and I don't say this because I'm
happy about it this happened before I
was even born but you start to realize
that these guys aren't telling you the
whole picture and it's like honestly as
a viewer I was disappointed when I
figured this stuff out
so
and I and this got me thinking why are
they so gung-ho about marriage they have
to know
what divorce court is like there's no
way they don't know
and what I realized is that I started
Googling the ages of the men that I I am
thought the most about that push
marriage and family so this was Matt
Walsh Ben Shapiro
um I think I had
there's one or two others that I had in
there we're gonna pull up the Tweets in
a second but and I noticed they're all
under the age of 45 and then I Googled
the average age of first divorce
um which and I've seen some some people
are saying it's younger whatever but the
average age of first
divorce that I found was 44 for women
and 46 for men
um but you know if we follow the
trajectory of the average woman gets
married at about 30 nowadays maybe it's
late 30s okay and usually the man's a
couple years older so early 40s
and my my point about this actually was
that oh I get it they don't know
they have not them and their friends
they're too young to have gone through
the ringer of Divorce Court to know what
they're pushing men to sign up for now
I'd like to say I do think marriage is a
beautiful thing I think marriage is
amazing but I see no indication that
marriage is a good deal for men in 2023.
um let me like let's just like let's do
a thought exercise okay
the 60 to 80 year olds of today got
[__] in divorce court
uh it wasn't uncommon the 40 to 60 year
olds of today also got [__] I'm sorry
guys I'm swear I don't I don't know what
to tell you the 40 to 60 year olds of
today also got screwed in divorce court
so now I I see them all reacting to
these people on whatever all these women
on the streets they know that the
quality of women is worse than ever
before and yet they push them into and
yet they push men into a feminist system
that really is a death sentence to men
I you know you know and they don't know
they're not on the other side of this
but you know I I do interview after
interview of man there is something
about a guy that doesn't have access to
his children and wants nothing more to
be in his kid's life this isn't uncommon
this isn't a fringe case this happens to
men All Over America every single day
to the point that I started asking my
Uber drivers
why they ended up doing Uber and I found
Uber driver after Uber driver after Uber
driver who did not have access to his
children this is common but it is much
more common and devastating to the
average man
rich men live in a different reality
rich men typically can recover after a
divorce it's devastating their wife
takes a bunch of their [__] but rich men
got rich for a reason and a lot of the
times they can figure it out but the the
real the the men that I find that commit
suicide the most are average men that
work to the same job for 20 years maybe
a factory worker maybe a plumber an
average man who spent 20 years making
the right decision or 10 years whatever
it was
accumulating wealth
just for their wife to take their
pension
and what happens is the wife spreads
lies of them being an abuser now I'm
gonna give you guys an example I covered
the Stephen Crowder case
the daily wire Candace Owens covered
that case and pushed an edited clip that
insinuated that Crowder was an abuser
you know and that was a private clip
from his home now the reason I'm
pointing this out isn't to [__] on
Candace is not to hate on The Daily wire
but to point out that this happens to
men All Over America this is not
uncommon and while you saw in the
Crowder divorce that a clip was pulled
and you know everybody said he was an
abuser even though there was no court
case
there was no criminal court case that
definitively said he was an abuser we
saw trial by association we're now
seeing it with the Russell Brand case
and what I realized is there's no way
for men to interact with women without
there being a consequence
um and I and I still have yet to see any
retractions from them I'm waiting
because
I mean wrong is wrong what will happen
to these guys is a lot of times they're
kicked out of their own home with one
phone call so you can do one call get
you kicked out of your own home he's
then thrown with an abuser rape charge
she disparages his name all over town
I've even talked to men that the woman
convinced his family that he was a
rapist
zero evidence zero proof she did not go
to criminal court and in family court
it's based on a balance of probability
so that means she has to cry to one
judge and one judge gets to determine if
it was more likely that he did it than
didn't do it and it is not based off of
evidence I have seen cases where a woman
tried to get a man to abuse her
so she could take it to court and there
was text evidence of her
texting her friend
attempting to get this guy to abuse her
so she could take his money and the kids
and do you know who got primary custody
the woman because what will happen is
they'll say it's for the best interest
of the child the woman has spent the
most time with the kid in the last year
but why is that usually because in the
divorce process or it could just be
child support and alimony or child
custody case
the woman will not let the father see
the child so we're actually in a country
where men do not have access to their
own children a man cannot have a child
in America
and it be his because he will always be
at the mercy of the mother or pray to
God that he gets a judge that sees his
side that's the reality we're living in
and when you push young men that have no
idea that this system is so unfair into
marriage I think it's really
irresponsible
because they have no idea what they're
up against none
and my this isn't an attack on marriage
and this is not me saying that men
should never get married
um what I am saying is that you should
approach marriage with Extreme Caution
and regardless of what I say this is
what men are doing
um sixty percent of men aren't looking
for marriage or relationships
I didn't I I didn't tell them to do that
on top of that it takes on average a man
to date a woman three years in order to
get a ring
men are trying to mitigate the risk and
they want marriage and family but until
the divorce laws are changed I see very
little indication that there will ever
come back so virtue signaling and saying
wow marriage and family is the answer
without changing the divorce laws is
just sending another round of men to get
abused and oftentimes commit suicide due
to a system that discriminates against
them men only get primary custody of
their kids 10 percent of the time men
are the majority of child support and
alimony payments
men are tired of paying for women to
abuse them in court they are tired and
the truth of the matter is a man
actually would be better off a happy
single bachelor in his 50s rather than
some of the outcomes that I have seen in
this divorce documentary now this isn't
me saying that a man can never
have a happy outcome this is not me
saying that there are no ways to
mitigate risk but this is me actually
pleading to the Daily wire in
conservatives that we need to change
these systems if you ever want to see
families come back and until you start
lowering the risk
you will not see marriage and family
continue
and for some reason this opinion
gets me [__] on this opinion gets me
insulted
this opinion
has has conservatives attacking the
person and not the argument I'm going to
show you guys a video that Matt Walsh
made about me which I would love to
debate you on this topic actually
because genuinely I just don't think you
know what you're talking about I don't
think you're malicious but until I I am
begging you you all need to spend a week
in family court because you have no idea
what you are sending men up against none
um so let's let's pull this clip from
his show and in my career defending the
institution of marriage and I defend it
because it's the Bedrock of civilization
so it deserves defending and I defend it
because it's under constant attack so it
needs defending and one of the most
troubling developments in recent years
which we've discussed on this show in
the past is that these attacks are
increasingly waged not just from the
left but from certain noisy segments of
the right as well some right-wing
influencers with Legions of young mostly
male fans had decided that men should
abandon marriage and family life and go
their own way and these these
influencers many of whom consider
themselves a part of the so-called red
pill movement pretend to despise
feminists and yet have essentially
arrived at the same conclusion as
feminists which is that we should give
up on the family the two sides hate
marriage almost as much as they hate
each other
now one of these influencers is a woman
named Pearl Davis who has garnered a
relatively large following on YouTube
and various social media platforms she's
in her mid-20s single and childless and
Yet full of opinions about modern
marriage and family life a subject that
she has no personal insight into
whatsoever she spent the past few days
on the internet complaining about quote
unquote Trad cons like myself who she
says promote the nuclear family despite
not understanding what it's really like
yes we men who actually have wives and
children don't know what it's like to be
married but a woman who is not married
and has no children does know what it's
like in one of her tweets she wrote the
trade cons push marriage because they
aren't old enough to know better they
don't know the reality of what they're
pushing this is accompanied by a picture
of myself Ben Shapiro Michael Knowles we
aren't old enough to know better and
don't know the reality of what we're
pushing yet a woman who is younger than
us and single does know better and does
understand this reality another post she
goes on to say that marriage is a
terrible deal for men and she later
explains quote would you ever sign a
contract that fails 75 percent of the
time where your business partner is paid
to break the contract why would you
encourage men to sign that contract
until the terms are fixed now
you may be surprised to learn that
marriages fail at a rate of 75 percent
the figure that people like this
normally use is 50 and the claim that 50
of marriages end in divorce is already
spurious and we'll have more on that in
a moment but 75 percent
I was wondering where that number came
from so I scrolled down and I saw
something that she reposted from an
alleged lawyer who said this quote it's
not 50 50. that only accounts for
divorces another 25 on the negative side
for miserable men trapped in Cheaper to
Keep Her marriages unwilling to risk
Financial destruction and loss of their
children 75 chance of a devastatingly
bad outcome is just a bad plan no sane
person would enter into a commercial
contract on such terms
now I did ask him where he got this 75
figure from and uh he wouldn't say
apparently the magic statistic fairy
came and whispered it in his ear now for
her Park Pearl later tweeted a picture
of Pierce Brosnan with his wife of 20
years and she questioned whether the
marriage counts as successful since
Brosnan Brosnan's wife has put on some
weight at the age of 60.
so apparently even if they're happy and
have remained married for two decades
they still might fall into that 75
failure rate because they have not both
remained in supermodel condition into
their 60s this debate on social media
brought out the rest of the marriage
skeptical crowd on the right a bunch of
these uh red pill influencers decided to
hop on an emergency Zoom call and spend
two hours talking about me and the rest
of the daily wire crew and our Reckless
promotion of society's most fundamental
institution now there's there's one clip
here that you should see this is um
uh apparently a divorce a divorce lawyer
who says that the failure rate for
marriage is not 50 and it's not 75 it is
in fact even higher less
I think marriage can be successful of
course it's just not something that's as
scalable as we as a society are trying
to pretend it is marriage is and I've
said this a hundred times and I'll say
it 100 more marriages like the lottery
you are probably not going to win okay
you're probably not going to win don't
make that your 401k you're probably not
gonna win but if you win what you win is
so great that I don't blame you for
buying a ticket and trying I personally
don't buy lottery tickets but when
somebody says yeah I play the lottery
hey man Somebody's gotta win and you
know what as long as you're not blowing
money that you need for food or to put
shoes on your kids feet you're not
hurting anybody go out give it a try so
I always tell people listen marriage
when it works when you have somebody
who's married 20 plus years and they're
still crazy about each other that is the
exception not the rule
to me that these influencers think
through the authority on marriage when
they've been married what 10 15 years I
mean you know a lot of people enjoy
their marriages in their 30s but you
know 40s 50s is a little a little
different
my my point is is a man with a marriage
and family very familiar with divorce
law
is is a man with a wife and kids that
his friends you know he's in a he's in
an upper class Circle which upper class
people tend to stay married longer
um real and and based on everything he
says it doesn't seem like it because
again you don't know what you are
sending men to sign up for
then um and and so he wants to know
where I got the 75 stat so I'm gonna I'm
gonna break it down for you
so what what you seek Matt doing is
coping and coping is trying to make the
reality of the situation better than it
is now guys I came from a two-parent
home I have no reason and and I'm a
chick marriage benefits me I have no
reason
to cope I have I have no I have every
reason to make the stats look better but
when you really start uncovering the
whole like opening up the hood on what's
going on in America you realize that
it's a very small percentage of
marriages that succeed so I'll give you
an example
we are so we have you know and he's
gonna what did he say it was 45 divorce
rate
this is what they'll do they'll say oh
it's 40 not 50 oh oh well if you take a
pill with the 40 and not a 50 failure
rate that's so much better
you know really if you want to see the
state of family in America I really
think a better way to measure it is kids
and one out of three kids are alienated
from their father in the first three
years of life
that's one out of three but let's let's
let's go down the marriage route okay
let's go down the marriage route so
let's say we're gonna we're gonna round
okay please don't get triggered daily
wire we're gonna round
you know I'm gonna give you 40 percent
of marriages fail
why do we have phrases in society like
it's cheaper to keep her happy wife
happy life and why is the general
outlook on marriage bad in society are
they making it up or is it possible that
the majority of marriages are actually
not happy and it's really just the man
slaving away to whatever the woman wants
for a lifetime how many wives in society
obey their husbands truly you know
another thing Matt Walsh responded to me
on was I really hate the phrase let me
ask my wife
why if you have authority in your own
house why do you have to ask your wife
for anything
and it's like these little telltale
signs where you just start to see that
men do not have authority in their own
home and the reason is because when
you're in a contract and one person is
paid to leave the person that is not
paid to leave is always going to be
trying to make the person that is paid
to leave happy
now before you attack me personally as
the daily wire does is what I'm saying
untrue is the general consensus in
America that marriage is good and is a
net positive and their parents had happy
experiences with marriage I think if you
say yes you're being a little bit
disingenuous so going by this logic we
can kind of conclude that okay half of
the people that stay married it's a
miserable marriage
then we have another then we have
another stat to throw in there what
percent of women get fat after marriage
and is that generally considered W for
men so you know let's ask Matt what do
the men say is is a woman gaining 50
pounds after children acceptable and why
can't we have
this conversation with the men is it
acceptable to gain 50 pounds in a
marriage and is that generally a success
for men so I asked the men 13 000 votes
do you do you think that's a fair
question and instead what you see from
the daily wire it's very like feminine
tactics I ask a question and they get
offended by the question that I ask
which is is it considered a successful
marriage if the woman gains 50 pounds
now women you know you might not like
this but this is how men see it and a
lot of you have gained weight in your
marriage and your husband is just too
afraid to say anything to you about it
he doesn't want the trouble but really
men find this embarrassing they find it
repulsive and the data is going to show
you that is it a W for your wife to gain
50 pounds after children so 73 percent
said no it's an l
18 said yes it's a w okay let's keep
going when most men sign up to marry a
woman if he knew she would gain 50
pounds down the line uh 5 000 people
participated in this one seventy percent
of men said generally no 30 to generally
yes so the don't you know don't take my
opinion take the opinion of 20 000 men
is this crazy do you think okay and
these are my questions not you because
again these influencers these
influencers live a different life I
understand maybe you didn't start off
Rich okay but the experience of a man in
marriage that starts off average and
becomes rich is different than the
average man in America okay and this is
who I'm talking about I'm talking about
the factory workers I'm talking about
the truckers I'm talking about the
average man that run this country no not
everybody can be rich none of us could
do what we do without those men
influencers live in a different world so
the average man in this country do you
think the average man has Authority in
his own home
I would argue
um you know and we I'm I could pull the
men on this do you think the average man
has Authority in his own home generally
yes or generally no do you think the
average man's wife stays in shape for a
lifetime generally yes or generally no
do you think the average man is wearing
a woman that is pure generally yes or
generally no now what they could say is
and this is typically what they'll do
just find a good woman but I could also
give you examples of women that had zero
red flags that did everything right and
did the same thing and the point of the
matter is yes there are ways to mitigate
risk when you have a system that is
paying women to leave when you have
social media that is also telling women
to leave when you have consumer buying
decision when you have corporations that
are also telling women to leave a higher
percentage of women are going to leave
than ever before the women in the church
don't even believe in submission these
days I've interviewed church girl after
church girl after church school and I
can say firsthand the quality of the
women in church has gone down there are
not enough traditional women to go
around
and it's very easy for the top one five
percent of men to tell them to just find
a good woman but even good women do the
wrong thing when they are paid to
so you know Matt Walsh again they
default to this personal attack and this
I am the authority on marriage because
you know I've been married for over a
decade 12 years ooh
sorry I'm not trying to be rude but ooh
all right you know I know many men that
were married 12 years and then got
[__] in their 40s you know it's all
sunshine and Rainbows in your 30s but
40s 50s 60s you know that makes you the
same as the men that got [__] over in
their 40s 50s and 60s if it works out
I'm happy for you I I'm not attacking
the men that make it work but what I am
saying is it is it is very risky for men
to do today and marrying young with the
women on the market today is terrible
advice for men in 2023. it's terrible
advice I think that every man is going
to look at the pros and the cons of each
decision and decide for himself so you
know back to the personal attack I am
married therefore appeal to Authority
I've been married 12 years my wife
hasn't divorced me I know better than
you well if you did know better than me
uh you don't seem to know much about the
family court system that I'm just being
honest us because I think if you did I I
don't think your rhetoric would be the
same so again the issue you're going to
get with tradcons is they're typically
above average in some way they are
living in a different reality tall
wealthy men successful men are better
able to recover after divorce it's the
average man the truck drivers
construction workers the plumbers that
are financially ruined and contemplate
suicide I interviewed the men on the
other side of this and they want to make
fun of me they'll say oh Pearl just does
some interviews guys seeing the look in
these guys eyes when they are
financially ruined their reputation is
ruined and they cannot see their
children do you know as a death sentence
to a man knowing that another man is
going to influence their children more
than them
and they have no say or authority that
is a death sentence to a man the the kid
that they're paying for
now a stepdad is going to spend more
time with the child and influence the
child more than your own blood that's a
death sentence so it's the average man
the truck drivers construction workers
the plumbers that are financially ruined
and contemplate suicide men are eight
times more likely to commit suicide
after divorce so you get these rich men
encouraging men to sign up for marriage
without warning them to any of the risks
they have spent little to no time
listening to what these men have gone
through and their solution is to just
pick a good woman and I'm not saying
there aren't good women out there there
absolutely are but even a good woman on
her worst day acts with spite women tend
to be spiteful and when you have an
entire system that makes money off of
women spiked even good women and you saw
that with the Crowder case no criminal
charges at this point yet everybody
labeled him as an abuser that was a good
Christian woman this happens to the
Christian chicks this happens too this
happens to Muslim chicks in the Western
World marriage is extremely risky for
Math and the comment section you get a
lot of men agreeing with me they have no
idea how much a woman changes during a
divorce and there's typically nothing
the man could have done
so do you know now I don't even I didn't
even know Matt's wife was on Twitter I'm
learning something new every day
so and this is where I want you to see
how even the right when they don't like
questions that I'm asking and and my
genuine question you might not like the
question but are the majority of people
that are staying married happy
you might say oh it's not about
happiness okay are most men getting what
they signed up for when they thought
when they got married
do most men have an obedient life do
most men have a woman that's in shape do
most men have a woman that gave them
multiple children it happens
but is that the majority so you know
Alyssa which I I genuinely guys I don't
know these people are I know Matt Walsh
but Alyssa
okay
you'll see she appeals to an attack
first attacking me and whatever you can
get your likes and there's always going
to be stamps to like back you up
whatever I shouldn't even respond to you
because you're just a grifter Pearl this
is the funniest thing I get thrown at me
okay I'm a grifter all right all right
yeah I I'm just so desperate for money
my life is just I mean guys I you know
what's so funny so funny about this you
guys picked me I was happy playing pro
volleyball it's almost as if Alyssa
something I said was true it's almost as
if something I said resonated with me
you know there's a ton of people that
post tweets and tick tocks and videos
about their life there aren't many that
get 2 million followers in a year I just
got 350k followers on Twitter after
five months six months it's almost as if
something I'm saying was true and I know
what they'll say they'll say pearl that
means nothing there's people with stupid
audiences all the time uh not not huge
male audiences women are easy to fool
not men
not man
um if you're not selling sex there's a
million women doing exactly the same
thing I'm doing
why did I blow up it's almost as if
something I said was true
or you know they also say I'm like some
conspiracy theorist I don't know or I'm
a PL I'm a plant right okay but I will
one more time so again you are full of
it my question is what I said true or
false uh it does not have the average
life of an average man in America
you are doing a disservice to
conservatives and will likely find
yourself a spinster with a negative
outlook on marriage that you were
spewing
um now she's attacking me you're a
grifter you're going to be a spinster
and this is this goes back to women's
defaults always shame guilt insult and
need to be right so what's she doing oh
shame on you shame on you for the words
that you're saying you have no idea who
we are I agree I don't know who you are
you make assumptions because you see
successful men expressing the positives
and getting marriage married and having
a family
no I'm just begging the question do rich
men have the same experience in divorce
and family court as an average salary
guy
is a woman more likely to stay with a
McDonald's worker or a famous YouTuber
worth 10 million dollars
like it you don't have to be insulted by
questions I think part of your issue is
that they are men not promoting marriage
that doesn't sit well with you for a
plethora of reasons about your own
upbringing and Outlook that I could sit
around and psychoanalyze all day so this
is the next thing that women do they
psychoanalyze you like they just start
they're like oh you have your trauma and
my parents are still married I have nine
siblings
yeah oh oh but you didn't see that
coming and no I I the reason I talk
about this is because I have seen and
spoken to the men on the other side
I have spoken to men and the guys this
is not they're gonna they're gonna try
to manipulate the stats to make it seem
like this is uncommon let's say it only
happens to 10 percent of men would you
ever take a pill that is a 10 percent
death rate which the situation you're
putting these men in is death to a lot
of men
talk to any men's rights activist
anybody that helps their anybody that
helps men get custody of their kids
it is so common for these men to kill
themselves it is so it is devastating do
you think Matt and I got married when we
had money
I don't really care if you did or you
didn't rich men have a different
experience in marriage and relationships
do you think that Matt do you think Matt
was wealthy at 25 and thinking wow I
have so much money I don't care if I get
married young and divorce at some point
because I can bankroll a divorce no I I
think if if men knew that divorce was a
guarantee after
building up their wealth I I would agree
that they would not sign up
but no I don't think much about like
this is the other thing women make
everything personal and about themselves
you know this this isn't about them I
don't really care
um their marriage I hope it works out I
would never wish divorce on anybody my
point is men under the age of 45 and
rich men have a different view on
marriage because they don't know what
it's like for the average man I would
have no idea what it's like if I didn't
conduct these interviews and research
for my divorce documentary when you
actually look into it it opens your eyes
and changes your opinion do you think
only now 12 years at the juncture of his
career he decided he would be
pro-married you'd be wrong on all counts
I see but she's just
okay this this girl's just this stuff is
just moving the goal post he and other
conservative men aren't selling people
on lies regarding marriage they're a
beacon of encouragement and the dumpster
fire of culture that promotes self God
forbid he shows the joys of marriage
even then Matt isn't forcing anyone to
get married yes but my my issue is you
are telling men to get married young
when in 2023 that's in terrible advice
and this is the thing guys it virtue
signaling is so easy
like if I was in marriage and family is
the answer guys I would look so much
better I would have ten times less
people attacking me this is why at the
end of the day love them or hate them
Russian fit Rolo tomasi all of those
guys are honest they're honest about the
State of Affairs you might not like them
but they're honest but you know saying
what sounds good and saying what is true
it is much harder to say what is true
when the truth isn't nice
promoting marriage is not a form of
assisted suicide stop insinuating as
much by Throwing Shade and posting stats
all as a means to gain views and clicks
okay one did she tell me to stop
throwing stats
isn't this the like facts don't care
about your feelings
um it is and and this is the thing for a
lot of men out there it is a form of
assisted suicide it absolutely is you
have no idea what you are talking about
John Hopkins said I 100 agree that we
shouldn't Chuck marriage but a 40 to 50
of marriages end in a divorce it's a
sign that the system is badly broken and
absolutely nothing is being done to fix
it marriage won't die tomorrow but it
will die eventually if something doesn't
change and that's my point guys I didn't
make this culture I'm 26 if anything I
should we should you know they've had 10
years to promote marriage reform where
has it been
um so now this is what I call Stat
coping uh the divorce rate is not 40 or
50 percent divorce is obviously more
common than it should be but the rates
are dropping and the commonly cited 50
figure is a myth besides even if it was
true that fifty percent end in divorce
it does not remotely
follow that your own specific marriage
has a 50 failure rate just like we can
look at the rate of heart disease in
this country but it doesn't follow that
each individual has the same likelihood
of developing it and there's nothing
that can be done to substantially lower
your odds okay so let's you know finally
the personal attacks are done we have
some real conversation
um I would argue the reason the divorce
rate is dropping is because people
aren't getting married on average it
takes a woman three years to get a ring
um
and
on top of that
there's a lot of men
that have seen all these other guys get
absolutely screwed in divorced and now
we have phrases like Cheaper to Keep Her
I don't say this with a happy heart
but the truth comes out eventually this
is what's happening
um okay so now he says just like we can
look at he Compares marriage to obesity
rights everybody's obese but you can
avoid it now I I think this would be
true if you were in control and had the
power but the truth is
there there can be stuff done to
mitigate the risk of marriage but when
you have a child she automatically has
the leverage and I have zero evidence
that would suggest that when women get
leverage they don't do the wrong thing I
mean looks well look what has happened
when we got our right to vote
um we took away the kids we spent a
bunch of money you know women just don't
tend to do the right thing when they get
leverage and even a good woman on her
worst day with a system that tells her
to do the wrong thing can do the wrong
thing
um
and honestly I have interviewed guy
after guy after guy that protected first
wife provided for his wife
and still had the same thing happen to
him
it is not a guarantee and I don't
believe that we should shame men into
doing it
with a system that profits off of women
doing the wrong thing
yes there are ways that can lower your
odds but
the pool of women is lower and worse
than ever before
even good women with a good background
can still be corrupted by social media
I see it all the time
and again you start to come to these
conclusions when you've interviewed
700 people would that give you any
insight any none really
all right you're right I know nothing so
then you know I just you know I'm I'm
kind of funny I'm a funny chick so I
said real men Marion squirt out baby you
have victim mentality find good woman
and squirt out baby so Ben Shapiro
weighs in he says marriage is good and
you should get married marriage will
make you a better person you should date
with an eye towards marriage seeking
commonality of values the single most
important foundation for a lasting
marriage thank you for coming to my TED
Talk does marriage in 2023 make women
better people
are we in better shape after marriage
um is there is there a reputation for
women switching up after marriage
now I know this kind of like breaks your
whole world view right I I I wasn't
happy about this either okay I I didn't
create this
but I'm sorry Ben until you change the
laws and and you guys have so much
influence gosh you got you guys are like
the most influential media Network why
is this not your first issue none of
this stuff will happen until you make
the laws more fair for men and shaming
men and calling them not real men
because they don't choose to sign up for
a system that profits off of them
getting divorced uh I I just I don't
think it's a good look for you guys
Jeremy Boeing all right here we go the
red pill attack on marriage is evil so
there we go that's shame insult you know
shame you even having this discussion is
evil divorce is also evil no fault
divorce is particularly evil divorce
when children are in the picture is one
of the most evil acts a person can
engage in okay we agree there all of
these acts of evil are common because
evil is common and we are all given to
it from time to time but that does not
change what they are the fact that women
initiate 80 percent of divorces evidence
that some manifestations of evil are
more common in women some think society
and frustratingly Christian Society has
been trying to obscure since we turned
over all of our moral authority to women
in the 20th century I I think I agree
with this mostly it is also evidence of
societal sickness one that creates
enormous incentives for women to divorce
and virtually though not absolutely none
for men the red pilled rightly observes
much of the sickness they even rightly
diagnose much of it oh but here it is
but then they turn on the institution
itself an institution fundamental to
human flourishing male flourishing the
flourishing of society and the
flourishing of children an institution
that is when rightly ordered the great
metaphor for a relationship with Christ
marriage makes man marriage saves men
and is a picture of salvation of men
um we should fight to make marriage
marriage we must defend men's rights in
marriage but we must not abandon
marriage to abandon marriage is to
abandon the fight beneath the fight the
fight which all other fights are
premised anti-marriage is anti-life you
cannot be conservative in anti-marriage
so now I'm not this is like the same
argument you're not a real conservative
all right all right I'm a fake one I
guess I don't know it's like it goes
back it's like the shame guilt insult so
it's like you're not a real it's like
okay what's more feminist okay
telling men to be cautious of a feminist
system sorry guys Family Court that's
feminism that is a feminist system uh a
institution that let's say let's let's
be generous let's say it's only 10
percent of men where every round of men
there's going to be 10 percent of men
that are financially ruined cannot see
their children and oftentimes have
insults of abuse the the family court
goes off of a balance of probabilities
and they have switched the definitions
of a lot of things for example abuse
abuse used to be a man hitting a woman
and that used to be the standard for
abuse for a woman hitting a man vice
versa but now we have things like
emotional abuse Financial abuse coercive
control like what the hell does this
[__] even mean they expand the
definition they make it Broad and then
they apply it to more men and use that
to take away their children and their
resources so let's think of marriage as
a business okay let's think of it
as a business that men sign men are the
consumers so they buy a woman now
they're in the marriage business okay I
know I know this is just just the
thought exercise
so let me get this straight if the
customers keep coming back to this
institution what incentive do they have
to change the only way that these
systems will change if is if enough men
walk away that it will hurt their
pockets in my opinion now whatever I say
I'm just a social commentator I I can't
change the laws but my point is when you
have 60 of men walking away from
marriage and relationships you have to
start to ask yourself why and you're
going to get a generation of men that
are not looking for marriage and
relationships and it's going to be
catastrophic this should be the number
one issue we're asking all politicians
right or left what is your solution to
amending the family court system
until that happens yes marriage is a bad
deal for men and it is extremely risky
and it should be approached with Extreme
Caution
and the next question I have is why do
we have this extreme simping why can't
we just say that men don't want fat
wives why must we defend wives that get
fat after children
um so I said
and I asked this question
this is a question you might not like
the question you might not appreciate
how the question makes you feel but I
thought I was talking to men
so I thought I thought we could ask
questions
um so James Bond another falling hero
got caught in the [__] trap stay free
stay single live to hunt another day
okay so we have his wife
um she's a hottie when she was younger
um and I asked the question and then she
gains like what is that 50 75 pounds I
mean this woman gained a lot of weight
this is I mean I know we have kids and
[__] but I mean [__] does this count as
a successful marriage would this be a W
for men everywhere and that is my
question Trad cons
um Now Matt Walsh came in and said but
they're happy
are most men typically happy with this
and what they'll try to do is is and
this is what I see from chadacons they
default to egalitarianism well he got a
little a little big too well men and
women don't select for the same things
women are supposed to be the beautiful
ones men are supposed to have status
they're supposed to have money I mean
when we look at what women select for in
2023 he's got both of those things this
is a world renowned actor that can't get
a woman that stays in shape now
is that acceptable as a wife let me know
in the comments and if we can't have
real conversations about what's
acceptable what should men be asking for
from wives then how will we ever see a
change